you were in the post this is a movie
that you know Tom Hanks is in this movie
Meryl Streep directed by Steven
Spielberg when they're when you're in
that setting don't you leave your body a
little bit and think I mean I knew you
when you were selling corn cobs on the
street he did that's how he made us he
lived he comes from Naperville and in
Chicago he used to sell old corn cob
street and you were just scraping to get
by you had yeah yeah yeah it was amazing
to be a part of that film and and these
big projects you know I yes
it's intimidating and weird and I have
to act like I'm not freaked out all the
time but right a great honor a great
part and it probably does help you that
you can always they don't know you could
be freaked out around these big stars
but we don't know when the masks look at
the face of Bob Odenkirk you don't know
what he's thinking no glee just no no
not ugly at all but just we don't know
what you're thinking
well that weird don't do that you're
scarier when you smile actually yes all
right let's talk about better call so
yeah we I have watched every single
episode of this show I absolutely loved
it
and when I heard about the project as a
huge Breaking Bad fan I remember
thinking probably gonna do yes how are
they gonna do it and it's been
beautifully exciting
really beautifully executed yeah as a
prequel and getting to know your
character and now what's great is that
the characters as the story goes along
we're seeing more and more of the
original Breaking Bad gang yeah so uh
you better call Saul yeah it's true and
in this fourth season more of those
characters come back from Breaking Bad
it's it's fun and exciting to get nearer
to that story cuz everything gets a
little more dangerous and scary and also
because Jimmy McGill Saul Goodman who I
play doesn't know what's coming which is
kind of this funny thing dude think
you're gonna die or you're almost gonna
die real soon man he doesn't die in
breaking bad but it he almost gets
killed a bunch of times so it's it's a
really neat journey and it's all Vince
Gilligan and Peter Gould these great
writers who created Breaking Bad
right this show and I guess we have a
clip from this season that yeah but
we're not ice we're not going to show
you've got a rake we'll be out of show
Don kid because I I'm going to show it I
just wanted to screw with you I knew you
and you were selling corn cobs on the
street who sells corn cobs
it's slided them they were very popular
they had a naked lady on the bottom yeah
yeah it was the late 80s and it was corn
cob mania check it out
okay we have a clip here from better
call Saul anything that you want to know
anything we need to know but - anything
- no that's a heist of the century
Jimmy's planning let's watch it let's
take a look
and what if I told you you could turn
this piece of crap into four grand for
each of us minimum this little fella
he's called the merry wanderer he's not
much to look at he's pretty easy to find
I got this one at a pawn shop on 4th for
20 bucks but he has a cousin called
Bavarian boy almost identical same
umbrella same swagger that one is worth
a boatload and I gather you know where
to find a Bavarian boy I do indeed he's
gathering dust on a shelf in an office
up on San Mateo and he's been there for
god knows how long and they have no idea
what they've got to them it's not a
variant boy it's just some piece of junk
grandma gave me that I feel too guilty
to get rid of and that's where you come
in now this place I'm talking about
they're not exactly what you call
security conscious there's no cameras
whatsoever there's an alarm on the door
that I could probably bridge and pass
that you just pick a lock and walk over
the shelf and swap this wanderer for
that boy in five minutes max yeah
Jonathan is amazing and Jonathan thanks
he gives many times he's been on this
show and he is that guy a little bit he
gives he flipped so much [ __ ] he just
loves to take this show and turn it
upside down when he get on and he has
those eyes that look right through you
but hard to do scenes with him sometimes
I love it so much it makes me laugh
every time as soon as they say cut I
break into laughter because so intense
yeah he's a little bit like the
character except he won't kill you yeah
he was up til that up everything else
about I'm like let's do this I did it
that's how you do it what do you want
that's wonderful I got a great cast
Jonathan banks yeah on horn wonderful
show better call Saul
airs Monday nights at 9:00 on AMC make
sure you watch it because it is
absolutely fantastic and can you get
your posse out of here with what no no I
don't want them
[Applause]
[Applause]
you